the Joe Rogan experience well anytime
you want to go let me know this is
healing this weekend we're Vegas [ __ ] I
might come [ __ ] with come on down
hello let me think I don't want to say I
got thing too I got some there's at
least two titles right oh [ __ ] three
titles I can't go I'm going on Honduras
how do you forget you're going to
Honduras no I just be doing [ __ ]
are you sure whenever I get a chance to
now as far as traveling just for fun
yeah just for fun just for Chile is why
we have my me time my space time to
gather my thoughts and do my pay hmm
yeah so not even not work-related at all
just to join yourself that's kind of
where I'm at mentally and everything I
just I'm kind of pre retired in my mind
really to prepare myself for when when
[ __ ] slow down I think you should do
that I think I should with me for for
that when you buy for you need to
prepare for sixty I always try to
prepare for late I'm 52 so 60s around
the corner for me negative 50 I'm just
realizing because I remember when I was
a kid and I used to be like man and I
want to I want to give my life to God
you know that but ain't gonna have no
fun i'ma wait till I get about 50 and it
hit come 50 about to pull up [ __ ] so now
I mean but on the fifth is a cool cool
age and and I'm just and I'm just start
preparing for when when I can't take
care of myself
but what it all is is that we know it
ends and we don't know when we don't
know if it's 100 we all it's 80 we know
it else so you hear 40 and you go oh how
close how close my which I know it's
about time to wrap up I don't went half
the century like what's the average 100
at the most so I'm like yeah all right I
know this [ __ ] for the end pretty soon
some type of way so yeah let me prepare
and then I look at I watch old people
like so I pay attention to them so I see
what they going through them like I it's
my turn pretty soon I had John
Witherspoon in earlier in the year with
his side of the large ad yeah
and he died shortly after he died late a
couple months later and uh I've known
that guy for a long time and I remember
thinking like he was just here he was
like happy he had all this energy he was
hilarious and then a couple months later
the lights shut off that's life man
that's life
That's Life that's life that could just
like that in the big scheme of things
from thousands of years it's just like
that but a guy like that is just like
iconic figure hilarious comedian like
he's is it's weird that he's gone you
know why because it's weird when
everybody leaves it's like they're just
they're just it's just they're not in
this space anymore you know it's just
gone I don't see it as weird though cuz
I see the F is just as much as life it's
the same thing so I don't see it as
weird I mean of course emotionally we
had motion attached to it bothers us you
know but at the same time I get it yeah
that's what I think it I think that's
the key to all this [ __ ] understanding
once you understand you just you can't
pretty much got life figured up you
think you have life figured out I never
feel like that I never felt I got life
figured out yeah you think you got it
nailed I mean it's tough to learn like
I'll just tell them stuff like this
they've just opened my mom's the stuff
he was just telling me stuff but all the
float tank but the beginning and it's
pretty much life and death just like
it's just like any other thing in life I
mean any other thing that's living
there's nothing no no difference so it's
like we just think it is because this
[ __ ] he'll make us arrogant that's true
and I also think it's a thing it's a
manager perception thing you know like
you have to manage your perceptions like
how you view things so you could freak
out about things or you could just
everything is perception is everything I
mean it's just how you look at it in
this that's what keeps you sane
understanding like it's just how you
look at it and understanding there's no
good or bad and [ __ ] is what it is you
just got to be on the right side yeah
and the universe doesn't care just keeps
marching the universe nature don't give
a [ __ ] I taught at all nothing is more
powerful in nature and once we realized
it
we'll be mo humble you said you saw cats
hunt on a safari yeah what was that like
I got it on my phone
[ __ ] you see him get one uh you got to
sit there for a minute and I don't hear
no weed and
[Applause]